I'm left with a man all right let's get
this over with home on the range yes
okay out of all the Disney films I was
gonna see for Disney cember this is the
one I wanted to see the least and let me
tell you folks it didn't disappoint it
gave me exactly what I thought I was
going to get oh god do I hate this film
this is right up there with the
Aristocats just no creativity no
spontaneity no passion no effort just
pure phoned-in
Ness I'll tell you the story because
really you can figure out pretty quickly
if you'll like this film or not Rosanna
is a cop well I'd press stop after that
fact but let's keep going she's just
been sold to a farm with other cows and
everything is happy and chipper they
dance they smile they yeah but then they
find out that the farm is being closed
down so the cows figure that if they
bring this bandit to justice and get the
reward money they can use that to save
the farm and that's it the rest is cows
going after an evil villain
it's about as half-assed as you can
imagine okay now let me make one thing
clear when I say half-assed I mean
half-assed for Disney
I know animation is hard I know that by
most normal standards this is still
pretty good animation and I know that by
most bad films and even bad children's
films consider this isn't that
horrendous but if somebody told you that
this was from the greatest animation
company in the entire world admitted you
be a little cheesed off too you would
want to see more effort from something
that's so massive and so large and this
is a movie that's obviously just geared
towards little kids I mean really little
kids toddlers the jokes aren't for
adults the writing isn't for adults the
characters aren't for adults even the
animation style isn't really for adults
and again that was the magic with Disney
they hit both they could hit both the
kids and the adults but here
it's just for kids the only thing I
remember remotely laughing at was
jennifer Tilly as this one account and
to be honest it's Jennifer Tilly
she's always funny aside from that I
remember so little the songs are
forgettable the characters are
forgettable the Imagi sness of how
bright and colorful and smiley it is oh
it's like something out of Barney the
Dinosaur or something it just doesn't
seem like Disney or maybe it does but
not updated Disney not current Disney
not the Disney that kept us coming back
wanting more not the passion not the
drive uh I don't even know what else to
say about it it's just bad with a lot of
these Disney films I was forced to watch
this month I came across a few surprises
sadly there was no surprise with this
one at all unless you're only a few
years old or younger I say this is a
definite skip